When the gods granted King Midas one wish.
He wished that everything he
touched would turn to gold.
Midas was delighted trees,
rocks, buildings, all gold.
But soon he found in horror that
his foods turned into gold as well.
When he hugged his daughter
to soothe his pain,
he realized his mistake too late.
The richest man in existence was starving,
heartbroken and alone.
Humanity got us similar.
Wish granted when we learned how to
turn Brown, stinky goose into magic,
plastic, cheap, sterile and convenient.
It changed our lives,
but this wonder of technology
got a little out of hand.
Plastic has saturated our environment.
It has invaded the animals we eat and
now it's finding its way into our bodies,
his plastic.
For most of our history,
humans use stuff we found in nature
to build the things we need it.
But the invention of plastic
roughly 100 years ago,
completely changed our world.
Plastic is made from polymers,
long repeating chains of
molecule groups and nature.
Polymers exist everywhere.
The walls of cells, silk hat,
insect,
carapaces DNA,
but it's also possible to create them
by breaking down crude all into its
components. And rearranging them.
We can form new synthetic polymers.
Synthetic polymers have extraordinary
traits. They are lightweight, durable,
and can be molded into almost any shape,
not requiring time consuming.
Manual work.
Plastic can be easily mass produced and
it's raw materials are available in vast
amounts and incredibly cheaply.
And so the golden era of plastics began.
Bakelite was used for mechanical parts,
PVC for plumbing,
electric guitars and cases,
acrylic as a shatter resistant alternative
to glass and nylon stockings and war
equipment. Today almost everything
is at least partly made from plastic.
Our clothes, phones, computers,
furniture, appliances,
houses and cars. Plastic has long
ceased to be a revolutionary material.
Instead it became trash, coffee cups,
plastic bags or stuffed a rapper.
Banana. We don't think about this factor.
Lot plastic just appears and goes away.
Unfortunately it doesn't
sense.
Synthetic polymers are so durable.
Plastic takes between
501,000 years to break down,
but somehow we collectively decided
to use this super tough material.
The things meant to be thrown away.
40% plastics are used for packaging in
the u s packaging makes up one third of
all the waste that is generated annually.
Since its invention,
we have produced about 8.3
billion metric tons of plastic,
335 million tons in 2016 alone,
more than 6.3 billion metric tons of
plastic have become waste since 1907 piled
up in one place that makes a cube
with a side length of 1.9 kilometers.
So what did we do with all this waste?
9% was recycled,
12% burned,
but 79% of it is sticking around.
Still a lot ends up in the ocean
around 8 million tons a year.
That's so much plastic that it will
outweigh all the fish in the ocean by 2050
because it's everywhere.
Marine animals keep getting trapped
in plastic and swallowing it.
In 2015 already,
90% of seabirds had eaten plastic.
Many animals, staff with stomach's
full of indigestible trash.
In 2018 a dead sperm
whale washed up in Spain.
He had eaten 32 kilos of
plastic bags, nats, and a drum.
While this is tragic and makes
for great magazine covers,
there's an even more widespread in
visible form of plastic microplastics.
Microplastics are pieces
smaller than five millimeters.
Some of them are used in
cosmetics or toothpaste,
but most result from floating waste that
is constantly exposed to UV radiation
and crumbles into smaller
and smaller pieces.
51 trillion such particles float in the
ocean where they are even more easily
swallowed by all kinds of marine life.
This has raised concerns among scientists,
especially about health risks from the
chemicals that are added to plastic.
BPA for example,
makes plastic bottles transparent,
but there's also evidence that it
interferes with our hormonal system.
Dehp makes plastics more
flexible but may cause cancer.
It would be pretty bad if microplastics
are toxic because they travel up the
food chain.
Zero plankton eat micro plastic.
Small fish eat zooplankton,
so do oysters,
crabs and predatory fish and
they all land and our plates.
Micro plastics have been found in honey,
in Cecil and bear in tap
water and in the household.
Dust around us.
Eight out of 10 babies and nearly all
adults have measurable amounts of fights.
A common plastic additive in their bodies
and 93% of people have BPA in their
urine.
There is little sons about this so far,
and right now it's inconclusive.
We need a lot more research
before panic is justified,
but it is safe to say that
a lot of happened that we
didn't plan for and we have
lost control over plastic to assess
the extent, which is kind of scary,
but just to make sure we should
simply band plastics. Right?
Unfortunately,
it's a bit more complicated than that.
Plastic pollution is not the only
environmental challenge we face.
Some of the substitutes we'd use for
plastic have a higher environmental impact
in other ways.
For example,
according to a recent study by the Danish
government making a single use plastic
bag requires so little energy and produces
far lower carbon dioxide emissions
compared to a reusable cotton bag that
you need to use your cotton bags 7,100
times before it would have a lower impact
on the environment than the plastic
bag. We're left with a
complex process of tradeoffs.
Everything has an impact somehow and it's
hard to find the right balance between
the plastic also helps solve problems
that we don't have very good answers for
at the moment.
Globally.
One third of all food that's produced is
never Eason and ends up rotting away on
landfills where it produces me thing
and the best way of preventing food from
spoiling and avoiding unnecessary
waste is still plastic packaging.
It's also important to note where the
vast majority of the world's plastic
pollution is coming from.
Right now,
90% of all plastic waste to entering the
ocean through rivers comes from just a
10 rivers in Asia and Africa.
The Yangtze in China alone flushes 1.5
million tons of plastic into the ocean
each year. Countries like
China, India, Algeria,
or Indonesia industrialized as an
impressive pace in the last few decades
transforming the lives
of billions of people.
This development was so fast that the
garbage disposal infrastructure couldn't
keep up with collecting and
recycling all the new waste.
This broad if politicians in Europe
and the U s want to address this issue,
investing in infrastructure and developing
countries is just as important as
fighting plastic pollution at home with
campaigns and redesigning products to
minimize unnecessary plastic production.
The bottom line is,
as long as we don't address plastic
pollution from a global perspective,
we will not solve it. Plastic
pollution is a complicated problem.
We found a magic material and we
had a really good time with it,
but we need to be careful,
or just like midas will end up in
a world that we didn't wish for.
Your individual daily actions
still have a huge impact.
What you do matters.
Refused disposable plastics.
Convince your friends and family to
do the same pressure companies and
politicians to take the necessary steps
to keep our oceans clean and our food
safe.
Together we can beat plastic pollution.
This video was a collaboration with
UN environment and they're clean seas
campaign. If you want to take
action to turn the tide on plastics,
go to clean seas.org and make your pledge.
Okay.